listen i want to save you time in
scouring the internet to find the right
people to follow when it comes to
growing your personal brand with video
there are a handful of successful
entrepreneurs who are harnessing the
power of video to get in front of more
people and in doing so are scaling their
businesses and brands and as a college
dropout myself i want to learn from
people who are doing it right so on this
episode of the grow it video live show i
am sharing with you seven entrepreneurs
that you should be following right now
to grow your personal brand with video
all that and more coming up in the show
[Music]
welcome back to the grow with video live
show my name is heather torres i am one
of the hosts of this show and man we are
bringing a power packed episode to you
sharing with you the entrepreneurs that
you should be following but if you're
new here i want to i i want you to
consider subscribing if you're ready to
learn how to grow your personal brand
with video and i want to jump into the
first entrepreneur that you should be uh
following but before i get into that i
am joined by two amazing co-hosts from
the think media team sean cannell and
omar el tacori sean are you excited
about these seven entrepreneurs i am i'm
super fired up you know i believe that
lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
and we live in the most incredible age
where we can be mentored by the internet
you know we can actually have people on
uh podcasts and especially youtube
channels that can coach us and share
their experience their wins and what i
love about all these people is we're
really going to be sharing you know be
careful who you follow be careful who
you trust and we've done our due
diligence we know some of these people
personally and details about their
businesses so it's going to be a power
packed episode of why we can learn from
some incredible leaders how about you
omar
man you said lifelong leaders are
lifelong learners i would say show me
your feed and i will show you your
future
and who you're following uh is is is
literally heading in the direction i
just signed up for tick tock by the way
and like my goodness like the amount of
the the default algorithm that it's
serving was kind of like i had to get
off really quick if you know what i'm
saying but when you can really uh make
your social media experience educational
man every time you open up your social
media app it's no more it's no longer
trash or every time you open up youtube
you're being met with good information
so i'm pumped because these people have
really built um a reputation and and
like you said we know a lot of these
people so i'm pumped to get into all
these uh
entrepreneurs you know what i'm saying
yes yes well i am excited we're going to
jump into number one and uh wanted to
let you know too that this show is
brought to you by grow with video live
which is our in-person and online
experience that's going to be happening
in may 2022 if you're watching this show
right now you can actually get a
discount by going to grow with video
live and using the uh discount gwvl
show to get five percent off i'm going
to tell you more about some other
details of this conference in just a
little bit but i want to bring on
entrepreneur number one which is
actually the author of the hundred
million dollar or he's the author of the
book 100 million dollar offer and alex
hermosie is a entrepreneur on the rise
him and his wife layla um they have
actually been growing uh businesses
offline and now they are coming online
and he's growing his social media and
his youtube channel
really really fast doing some very
interesting strategies sean i'd love for
you to share just some of the strategies
that alex is using um and why you should
be following him as an entrepreneur
yeah alex is kind of a new kid on the
block in a lot of ways because him and
his wife were head down building
businesses they built a
business called gym launch i believe to
27 million in one year and they've sold
a few businesses and so now as they've
kind of stepped into the content arena i
think what we love about them we first
discovered it by the book if you haven't
heard of the book 100 million dollar
offer we'll by the way link up all these
creators as well as their um their
resources like the book highly
recommended um and that's what first
kind of impacted our company we bought a
copy for multiple team members um but i
think uh alex is just super tactical and
he's really next level um as far as
business advice operation advice cut
through the noise um and i also think
his content strategy is uh something
that's pretty impressive um he's doing a
lot of vertical video and getting a ton
of views there his youtube channel has
been growing very quickly
and so also the fact he's speaking at
growth video live one of the things i
haven't ever heard him share is how he's
grown his personal brand uh in the way
that he has in just really a matter of
months in fact let us know in the
comments have you heard of alex hermosie
yet or not are you just here because
he'll probably be on your radar soon but
hundreds of thousands of subscribers in
a short time and so uh yeah really
really love them and and i think a lot
of people sometimes do kind of service
level stuff which is great or like
helping us get started and for beginner
stuff alex and his wife layla who's also
speaking at the event are uh our next
level they're like how do you scale or
you feel stuck at six figures or
multiple six figures not that you can't
learn from them as a beginner it's kind
of the information you wish you had when
you hear about it but really if you're
ready to scale uh they're pretty
incredible but uh heather back to you
yeah and i think one of the things that
i love about what alex is doing is even
in this clip you can see here i mean
omar i'm sorry this probably hurts your
soul but alex is in a closet using a
webcam to make his content so he's
really breaking the barrier down too for
busy entrepreneurs who are just trying
to get their content out there um he's
really breaking down the barrier of
making sure obviously that that he is on
camera and he's using a good microphone
but he's really harnessing the power of
editing omar in his videos you've seen
that uh on his content
no for sure i this is this is just a a
truth all across any platform that that
content value is more important than
production value and so what what alex
is bringing is is he's bringing the last
decade of his experience to his personal
brand and what he's learned in the
successes he's had and i think that can
speak to a lot of people who are
probably watching this show is you're a
professional you've been doing a thing
that a lot of people are getting into
and you you know if you think of uh your
approach to online video like you need
to do it a certain way i would actually
say
who do you just need to help because you
know like like shawn mentioned that alex
has really
created a way of getting in front of
people and just sharing valuable content
and i think uh he's also somebody who's
shown me that like the internet could
spot a fake you know like he's the real
deal he he's actually built something
and so i think he's worthy of follow and
worthy of getting in your feeds whether
it's on instagram uh tick tock or even
youtube
and we'll make sure to drop all of these
entrepreneurs down below because uh the
swedish car guy says i never heard of
alex yeah alex is on the rise um
definitely taking over uh um the
entrepreneur space on youtube and it's
really exciting to see but we're gonna
bring up entrepreneur number two and
again these are in no particular order
but if you're getting value will you
smash the like button really quick if we
just showed you a new entrepreneur that
you didn't know you needed to follow
smash that like button uh and number two
i mean sean i think most entrepreneurs
online know about gary v and you have a
very particular story about how this
company think media was really started
because of your interaction with gary
vaynerchuk i'd love for you to share
that really quick but gary vaynerchuk is
an entrepreneur who uh most people don't
even know has actually been on youtube
basically since it started he started
with his wine library tv answering
specific questions and reviewing
specific products wine online and when
he um when he started that he knew that
video was going to take off so he's
really been like a video pioneer in the
space of entrepreneurship and i i love
his strategy which is actually what i
call the blitz strategy which means how
much content can you put online at one
time this is garyvee's strategy and even
though he is running uh a youtube
channel now with over three million
subscribers he's got an instagram
channel with millions of subscribers
tick-tock millions of subscribers he's
just doing his everyday life and making
content out of it and i love that he has
become kind of the entrepreneur of video
when it comes to that shot i'd love for
you to share a quick story um about how
garyvee's actually impacted you of why
people should be following him
yeah and uh you know we're talking about
seven
binge-worthy
youtube channels to subscribe to of
course you can check out in the
description links to all of these and
our second one is garyvee now let us
know if you've heard of garyvee before
but uh garyvee kind of has a special
place in our company maybe like if when
you heard about him or when you
discovered him you know back what
happened for me is it's a pretty crazy
story it's very personal you know if you
haven't heard my story my wife almost
died and in 2009 she ended up in the
hospital for six days
and during that time i was super
overwhelmed i was working at a church we
were struggling financially we were
losing our home because of the big short
and i was kind of like i had already
started a youtube channel in 2007 i'd
already kind of started learning but i
definitely felt lost and i felt like man
i felt discouraged of course and
overwhelmed and so i walked across the
street to barnes and noble to
buy just to look for books or whatever
when my wife was sleeping in the
hospital i was by her side for six days
in seattle washington
and i bought a copy of success magazine
and back in the day they used to have
cds in the middle and that cd uh
had an interview with this guy named
garyvee high energy
you know you might know his vibe um and
he was talking about his book crush it
why now is the time to cash in on your
passion so actually the next day after i
put that cd into my 16 inch
17 or 18 inch
10 pound hp laptop and the cd thing and
listen to that interview i went across
the street and bought the book and i
actually read this in the hospital room
and you can see this early copy it's all
marked up again this book came out in
2009 and this is just one of the things
because you know gary's energy was like
why now is the time to crush it and cash
in on your passion and so uh it was in
that was part of the spark that was like
man i gotta go all in on this youtube
thing and then the social media and this
online thing and you know fast forward
today and here we are and years later he
wrote a book uh called uh now crushing
it and i didn't make it in the book but
there's actually a blog where uh they
were interviewing people who the book
who the book's uh life had changed and
um it's just kind of crazy so i know
some people are like oh gary curses and
that's like something that's hard for
them to overcome or some people like you
know they only get a snapshot and you
just get one polarizing clip from him uh
but his a lot of his social media advice
a lot of his tips i've continued to be
really helpful at think media but what i
also love is he definitely stays on the
edge so having him speaking live at
growth video live uh is just is huge
because he always brings something
really fresh that's exactly
for the now to help people get an edge
um how about you omar what do you think
about uh old garyvee
yeah i mean i just think he would be
the one the guy who's who has who has
paved the way when it comes to building
a personal brand as a ceo or somebody
who owns a business uh you know he he's
created even place uh jobs for people
like me i guess you could say you know
he has a guy named drock who has been
following him around for years and
whereas it used to be all about creative
videos and promos it was like hey how
about if you just follow have somebody
follow you around with a camera and then
it's kind of like the behind the scenes
of your life because you're doing
something that somebody else is trying
to do and another thing i like about
garyvee is i honestly just get i'm
always encouraged by his content i never
feel beat up because he's always uh
his message is usually possibility you
know like it's never too late to start
it doesn't matter how old you are you
know and and honestly he's he's a
perfect example of that i mean i think
he went all in and he was you know how
old is he when he when he essentially
went in on like the content creation for
his personal brand he was on the older
side and then we have you know 20
something year olds being like man i'm
not growing fast enough but uh really
really i just i love following him and
knowing like what is the thing he he is
pushing right now and you know things
i've been hearing lately is four tick
tocks trying to get in the game four
tick tocks a day
it's simple you know like yo and then
you'll find it again and you'll find it
again in another clip but i i you know
obviously nfts is kind of something he's
uh jumping into as well but uh i i just
appreciate his um his going over and
pioneering kind of what even grow with
video live is you know and it's so cool
that he's actually going to be a keynote
speaker
yes i think it's amazing and and
actually another thing uh that has
really inspired me and i hope will
inspire other entrepreneurs when it
comes to
content you could be creating to be
growing your business and brand is gary
actually has all these different shows
that he does on his channel too which
makes it really impactful to say you
don't have to box yourself in to one
type of content when you're creating but
the cutting edge the bleeding edge of
what gary is going to be bringing to
growth video live i cannot wait for you
to be in the room uh for this experience
and i want to give you just a little bit
about what growth video live is going to
be about this year this thing
is your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about but people would
rather complain about how it is than put
in the work we need to start
understanding how big this opportunity
is because for everybody in this room he
will sit back in 20 30 years and regret
if you didn't execute in this era it has
never been a better time in the human
race ever to actually just go all in on
you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
okay growth video live is coming up in
just a few short weeks and because you
are part of our grow with video live
show right now you're here you're live
we're watching the replay
you can get five percent off your
tickets and ticket prices are going up
so you want to make sure you lock in
your in person we have three different
levels for you to choose from in person
you can come as a general admission vip
or upgrade to that platinum experience
or we have two virtual experience
options for you if you're in another
country you're not able to travel at
this time you can still experience
everything growth video live has to
offer all you need to do is go to
girlwithvideolive.com use that coupon
code gwvlshow
to get five percent off of your ticket
today and then share on social media
because we are so excited to see all of
the attendees that are coming to grow
with video live let's get into number
three we're going to get to our third
entrepreneur so far we've covered
covered alex rosie gary vaynerchuk and
number three is vanessa lau i am so
excited if you do not know who vanessa
lao is because she is an entrepreneur
who is sharing her advice for young
entrepreneurs who want to be coaches the
coaching industry is exploding and
vanessa lau is an up-and-coming
entrepreneur who is sharing how she was
able to scale her youtube channel to
over 500 000 subscribers and 27 million
views she's sharing this though how to
do this with two main platforms youtube
and instagram and it's really
interesting to hear her story about how
she was working as a barista and then
became an entrepreneur by working on her
coaching business and she's sharing the
mistakes that she's made she's sharing
um how she was able to scale she's
sharing uh the different ways she's
using social media to be able to grow
her business and brand and sean i know
you're excited because vanessa is going
to be one of our speakers at grow with
video live this year and it's really
awesome to see young entrepreneurs who
are helping other entrepreneurs grow
their business
yeah 100 and and you know i think what's
a cool theme of growth video live this
year is
is that it's not a youtube conference
although
what you'll discover is that every
speaker the majority of the speakers
understand that youtube is like home
base like youtube's kind of like the
legacy platform the place to have the
longer form content the more depth the
you know greater kind of impact but
really um you know vanessa's crushing
instagram crush and reels of course uh
gary is everywhere with a big team
helping him alex is crushing vertical
video and of course we have the
opportunity to do vertical video now and
utilize youtube shorts
tiktok
and instagram reels three that's a power
play that if you're watching this you
definitely want to be leaning into and
so i'm super pumped for uh vanessa lao
being at uh growth video live um and
again what what like i loved how omar
said the internet can spot fakes
and so we just have like a real
meter of wanting to make sure that the
people who stand on our stage either
virtually or in person they have like
real business prowess they're not just
like they kind of got lucky on social
media once um or they have a shallow
business but you know vanessa runs a
team she's a leader uh she's got to
manage money and scaling her business
and managing multiple platforms and
creating product lines you know alex has
run multiple companies garyvee and
vaynerx
oversees multiple companies so it's kind
of the angle we're coming from respect
to the social media influencer world but
like these are business owners like this
is these are entrepreneurs that are
leveraging these digital platforms to
spread a message that matters to help
people to serve people in all kinds of
different ways too acquisition.com with
alex and gary has empathy wine he sold
that but there's all kinds of different
business models and verticals but we're
coming around this theme
of grow with video and how do you use
video to spread your message build your
income and make a difference in the
lives of people so vanessa definitely
embodies that and i'm pumped she's
coming yeah i am too i want to get to
this next entrepreneur um because this
is someone that i have personally
learned so many business principles from
um i think it's amazing when
entrepreneurs who have built businesses
like sean said uh come to the platform
with their experience their skills their
knowledge and they're sharing this
information for free and let me know in
the comments are we introducing you to
brand new entrepreneurs that you didn't
even know had youtube channels um this
next entrepreneur is patrickbetdavid and
he actually has a youtube channel called
valuetainment and valuetainment has
grown to over 3 million subscribers and
over 416
million views this is the channel where
patrick is sharing his advice on how to
actually grow and scale your business
personal development as well as
influential um uh interviews with people
like kobe bryant and jordan peterson and
he's someone who's actually again on the
cutting edge of how becoming a
multimedia company is the next wave for
entrepreneurs i love how uh uh the the
quote i'm not a businessman i'm a
business man by jay-z and that's what
patrick david embodies and sean i know
that for you personally patrick that
david has been someone who has inspired
you to really dig into the steps of
growing an online business because of
what we're seeing what valuetainment is
able to produce for their content
yeah 100 and you know let me know or if
you're on the replay or live if you uh
are familiar with valuetainment and
patrick bet david as a bold quote but i
actually think he's the most slept on uh
entrepreneur on youtube and that's hard
to say
uh or it sounds almost impossible that
you could have 3.36 million subscribers
but maybe you've never heard of him or
them um but he's out here 5.4 million
views a month 30 000 subscribers a month
pumping out videos um and he's really
the ceo of two companies again we're
bringing real business hitters he runs
an insurance company that i believe is
the founder of maybe with a couple
co-founders with i believe thousands of
agents
with tens of thousands of square foot of
office space across the united states so
we're talking about operating businesses
real leadership we're talking about real
business principles this is you can see
on screen some of the content that we
love from pbd is is just the fact that
he can really get into the critical
skills that it's more than just getting
views and getting subscribers you got to
learn business skills you got to learn
marketing you got to learn how to sell
if you want to be a youtube preneur a
content entrepreneur if you want to
build a real legacy and not just have 15
minutes of viral fame um patrickbetdavid
is for sure a great follow uh we'll link
up his book your next five moves very
highly recommended book that'll have you
thinking more strategically
um and again it's not a competition and
we're not pitting anybody against
one another uh but i would say when it
comes to entrepreneurship
depth business building depth of
knowledge i think that valuetainment's
probably the best of course everyone's
contributing the conversation hopefully
we're a small drop in the pond
touching on some of the things but we
want to give credit where credit's due
and honor works credits do others
sometimes kind of speak at maybe a more
beginner level or they don't give you
real tactical information pbd is
definitely crushing it when it comes to
really tactical information and you know
uh many of our speakers
are doing video podcasts and so i think
that's the other thing to kind of
consider is yes it's grow with video
live and yes it's youtube and shorts and
yes pbd just threw up the middle finger
on video and yes uh your next five moves
though you could see a copy of the book
on the back shelf um pbd is uh
uh the doing a video podcast is one of
the most powerful strategies for
leveraging video but then also expanding
your content onto
audio and you know i think uh omar's
kind of our resident video podcasting
expert and what we've discovered is that
you know it's not either or when it
comes to is it shorts is it tick-tock is
it youtube is it podcasting it's it's
step-by-step building an actual cohesive
strategy and a lot of our speakers are
going to be touching on that so because
to win in 2022 and beyond i think you
know
having a video podcast is something to
consider what are your thoughts on that
omar
yeah i mean i i definitely think what
patrick uh embodies is
what ceos could and should be doing it's
not necessarily where you know where
where vanessa lau is
essentially training you how to use
social media i think patrick that david
is showing us a model and when you see a
guy like this who's successful maybe i
would even argue he doesn't even need
you know he doesn't need to be posting
content but yet he organizes it
yeah his business hundreds of millions
of dollar revenue but he understands
that like posting content and i love
this about entrepreneurs ceos who who
know the value of this who's taking time
out of their week i need to shoot this
content i need to hit this interview i
need we need to get this on the calendar
and and so i think patrick that david
you watching him you're gonna get the
content on like what you should do for
your business but but i would also say
some people you can just watch their
model you know if you are a ceo or if
you are a business owner if you own
maybe your you have a medical practice
like look at he's taking time to create
content it's it's crazy it's weird
because like i'm a content creator i'm
like you know i don't i don't i'm not
hundreds of millions of dollars uh you
know and all that stuff but i could see
how entrepreneurs are like man i need to
prioritize this it's very important that
you build a personal brand if you're
trying to last i mean if you just want
to get quick you know money grab do what
you got to do cool but if you're trying
to last in this in for the long game uh
this building a personal brand is just
it's like uh it's like your your brick
and mortar store always at the corner of
that street you can trust that it's
there you know that you can go to that
uh convenience store buy that thing you
need and similarly showing up
consistently on social media on youtube
creates trust with the people and uh
then people who trust other people tend
to trust them with finances or uh you
know exchanges or transactions and so
yeah i'm pumped about him i really i i
love what he's doing i love watching the
stuff that uh i watched his house tour
in miami um and and even just how he
says like right here is where i shoot my
videos i'm like let's go somebody you
know got a youtube studio set up so pump
for him to be a girl with video live for
sure yeah and one last thing that uh
even what you're saying on their omar
that i hope helps people um overcome the
fear of having to have the perfect set
if there's one thing you've noticed so
far with every single one of these ceos
and entrepreneurs that we're sharing
with you is he's in his car guys i mean
it's really the content value over the
production value we're gonna help you
with the production value here at think
media which actually leads into the
fifth entrepreneur that you should be
following and i hope you're all already
following this entrepreneur that is sean
cannell so omar i would love for you to
come on and share a little bit about why
people should be subscribed not just to
think media but also to the think media
podcast because you know we run two
different channels and and grateful that
our ceo and founder of think media has
really unleashed um a new model for
people who start as solo creators who
then become um ceos and are able to
expand into other creators like you and
me being able to share that platform so
why should someone be following sean
cannell on all of the platforms omar
let me just say because i know him
personally and i've known him for maybe
close to 10 years or so uh is that sean
is the real deal when it comes to the
person who he is off the camera you know
like the way he leads the company um you
know and it spills over in the content
that you would find that that you know
he's a man of
values that are uh beyond you know are
you know here and now their eternal
values and uh he's he's building a
company on uh the word of god which is
something is that that's just
admirable
but it's the overflow effect that
happens from his personal life the way
he values his family uh and and raises
his son um and and how generous he is
but with that being said you have him
using
those values and or standing on those
values and create and helping people i
think you you uh mentioned it earl in a
post yesterday i believe like selling is
serving and uh we at the highest level
believe uh that selling something is
serving a people and we we i think media
believe or we're trying to help 10 000
purpose-driven uh entrepreneurs build a
full-time or part-time income using
video and we want purpose-driven i think
we hit 10 000 people but we want ten
thousand purpose driven because uh sean
knows that if you can impact the person
that cares about an audience uh then you
can impact a lot of people right and so
um i think the think media podcast
what i love is it's dialed you're never
gonna waste your time listening to
a think media podcast episode and it's
because sean takes the time to teach
through it it's not necessarily your
conversational one hour it's gonna be
you know around 20 minutes to 30 minutes
sometimes even shorter and you're gonna
get so much good content in such a short
amount of time a lot of people are
watching and listening to it twice uh a
lot of people take notes during his
podcast because it's very dialed on the
way he delivers his content and so yeah
i think the think media podcast is the
number one podcast to follow
uh if you're trying to build an
influence specifically with youtube and
youtube is way beyond just you and
vlogging and things like that no that
like it's it should be a pillar of your
business it's how you meet people before
they actually uh you know find you
because youtube is a search engine but
what shawn's been able to to do in
interviewing uh i think over 500
creators um over the course of the last
you know eight years or so he's been
able to really come down to like what
what is the the the go-to uh strategies
that you need
to grow on youtube and so think media
podcast for sure but that is not to
leave out the think media channel which
is uh our uh our channel where we are
teaching how to actually use a camera
how to actually use lights i believe
it's not you know i mean maybe you can
be biased but
it could be easy like if if you're
looking for a good setup i i mentioned
earlier that like content value is more
important than production value but one
way to stand out right away is to have a
good setup to have good audio to have
decent lighting um and if and if you can
if you can manage to do that then you
would be able to stand out earlier from
your peers and so think media is a place
where you can always get help if you're
if you need help with editing we have
editing tutorials if you need help on
how to set up your camera with settings
or how to dial in your audio or even if
you want to learn how to do live streams
like what we're doing right now this is
a live stream can you believe it that we
are like making our own tv show you can
actually do that and interview people uh
and create podcasts as well so
everything you want to learn about what
people are doing so it's almost like
everyone we've kind of mentioned here on
this show
we you can find a lot of that help on
how they're able to achieve whatever
they're doing and we saw patrick david
using a smartphone to create some
content we have videos on the best way
to use your phone did you know that you
should use typically use the rear camera
because it actually gives more higher
quality than the front-facing camera you
probably didn't know that but we teach
you on why you should use the
rear-facing camera and things like that
so i really just appreciate what shawn's
built would think media and uh honestly
the legacy he's leaving for other
entrepreneurs who uh you know have are
big on their faith family and uh
relationships
yeah and another thing uh too is if you
haven't picked up the book youtube
secrets one thing that i love omar like
look at this i'm just gonna hold up like
the people that are coming to grow with
video live that are speaking they're not
just influencers and no shame if that's
what people want to become where they're
just famous for being famous no the
people we're having on the stage at
growth video live are actual people who
have put in the depth of knowledge and
work into what they're doing and sean
cannell is none other than the
best-selling author co-author of the
book youtube secrets let me know if you
have a copy of this in the comments i'll
make sure to link it up down below um
but you know i think the other part too
omar we're going to be sharing this at
growth video live this year is people do
want to know like i just want to look
good on camera they want to look drippy
crispy like omar right now or they want
to have a set that's like this um and
one of the things we're going to be
sharing at growth video live this year
is just how to look good on camera let
me know if you're watching right now
live or on the replay is that one of
your questions how do i just look good
on camera because we're gonna be helping
you with that this year at growth video
live and you're watching right now the
growth video live show
and uh if you purchase your ticket this
week you can get five percent off by
using the coupon code
uh
gwvl show for five percent off of that
and i love this tony said he's gonna be
watching us virtually this time so that
he can join us for grow with video live
really really excited for that all right
omar let's go and get into some of the
last uh of the entrepreneurs that people
should be following on camera
all right so i'm following on camera
excuse me should be following on youtube
if you're getting value click the like
button omar do you have a favorite so
far did you have a favorite that we've
gone through so far i mean other than
sean obviously i know i mean i would say
somebody i've been gravitating toward
lately it has been alex alex hermosie i
think um i i appreciate not only the
value he's putting out but it's it's
just he's the case study of somebody who
doesn't need fancy equipment you know
and and just is sharing his knowledge
but showing up consistently uh but it
has been very impressive if you don't
know his numbers he really just went all
in with social media in january 2021 and
grew over 100 000 followers on every
platform which is crazy he hit that
milestone and then in three months by
march of this year 2022 man's done he's
over 200 000 but he's just showing up
like like i said the model he's showing
up consistently on video he doesn't even
change his camera position position for
his reels and stuff uh but no i he's
kind of like the new guy i've been i've
been loving to follow and i get a lot of
value from his content i love it i i'm
with james i've got a couple of
favorites but i think garyvee for me um
he's always just so uh he's so fun to
watch on stage because you never really
know you know what he's gonna talk about
and i think one one thing that i love
about what he's gonna bring to growth
video live is how to inspire
those content creators those
entrepreneurs to just pick up your
camera and press record because if
there's one thing that gary's been able
to do it is the blitz strategy it's the
idea of actually just posting content it
doesn't have to be perfect it doesn't
have to be fully polished but you've got
to be posting that's my p alliteration
for you today and jay i'm super excited
bought his tickets hotel book all you
need is the flight jay i cannot wait to
see you in person at grow with video
live this year all right we're going to
be getting into the next entrepreneur um
that you should be following right now
and the next entrepreneur is aaron on
demand and aaron on demand is an
entrepreneur who has been um up and
coming in the youtube space specifically
and what i love so much is actually uh
and i value so much with her content is
her vlog style content she's sharing
these concepts about scaling a um
stealing a new company of of starting a
startup company she's been sharing the
journey throughout her startup when it
comes to um the physical products that
she's creating but she's really doing it
in a way that allows for you to be a
part of it because she's storytelling
omar how important is it as a content
creator to be a storyteller in your
content we've seen this as a theme but
what i love is that aaron does this
really well in how she is presenting the
content to the audience
yeah i mean i you know i like to educate
people on like different video formats
and uh one format uh aaron does is is
vlogging vlogging is is really usually
having a camera that's usually wide like
you could see on here uh more of like a
wider shot but you're you're taking
people on a journey this is kind of like
talking head actually but i mean we can
pull up a vlog shot but taking people on
your journey
is is how you grow deep with an audience
you know and one reason i love the video
format of vlogging uh primarily is
because the constant movement that's
taking place i'm not saying shakiness
i'm saying movement you know like where
you're you're you're changing the shot
up consistently it keeps a viewer
engaged uh you know you're not you can
put your camera on auto and and you know
shoot vlogs but making vlogs
specifically is a format so maybe you're
showing somebody how to build an ikea
furniture thing you could shoot that sit
in you know one spot talk about it or
you can
show it you know throughout the time of
building whatever furniture you're
building so i think what's cool is she
she messes around with the different
types of video formats you saw that she
was doing a talking head video now she's
doing vlogs but taking a people along
your journey and sharing your story i
think it just gives you the permission
that you have a story to be shared you
know um she
she's been you've you can follow her
journey even uh on her youtube channel
from a place of where she was just
starting and not driving a nice car like
you see right now and then moving into
an office space and how she has set that
up um and and how she works alongside
with her significant other so i think
there's just so much to learn about her
if you're trying to really build like a
personal brand up close i think uh
somebody like um gary v patrick bet
david um you know they got they got
people filming their stuff you know
whereas
you know talk about
self-made entrepreneur where she's out
there filming she doesn't have a video
person she is the video person so she
you could definitely achieve what she's
she's doing um and learning again from
the format she delivers video in uh she
also has a lot of great videos on how to
you know do youtube you know in regards
to her setup and the cameras she use so
if you like what she's posting
specifically she has that content for
you as well
which is really smart because then you
know she's having affiliate links which
again showing should all encompassing
online business that she has built
through her youtube channel
yeah and i love i personally i watch
every one of her episodes omar because i
love that she
intertwines the behind the scenes and
the um the steps she's taking to do the
different things and it's just really
cool to be able to see different styles
of entrepreneurs you know where gary is
going to be blitz strategy make it messy
do all the things aaron does have a
little bit more polish in her
storytelling of what she's doing and
it's so awesome to see the progression i
can't wait for her to share her secrets
to success
on stage at grow with video live this
year well the next entrepreneur that i
want to bring up um is uh definitely
someone for us who has been such an
inspiration to what we're doing here at
think media and that would be chalene
johnson johnson um for me personally uh
has been a mentor for the last 15 years
um the first time i was introduced to
chalene was way back when she was doing
um fitness dvd she was selling them on
infomercials online and i was a new mom
who had gained like 70 pounds from
having a baby feeling horrible about
myself and i was one of those late night
callers who bought an infomercial a dvd
set from chalene johnson and from then
on i've been following her journey as an
entrepreneur she's been able to build
seven businesses to over seven figures
which i think is incredible i mean most
people are trying to just build one and
her and her husband brett and her family
are over here building seven businesses
to over seven figures and chalene has
been someone that's inspired me
personally not just with her fitness
journey but her um but for her values
and being an entrepreneur who is out
there in the world who is sharing um how
to actually do this without having to
subscribe to hustle culture so if you
are a mom a dad someone who really just
wants to make sure you're making time
for your family and not sacrificing your
family just for the fortune of life then
chalene is someone that you should
follow um chalene for me uh she is
helping people understand how to use
social media but she's helping you with
really the foundations of marketing omar
and i know for us here at think media
it's been such a gift because it's not
just about the video if there's one
thing about all the speakers who are
coming to growth video live it's it's
not that they're doing video it's that
they've built something behind the
scenes and then they're sharing how they
did it and that is one thing that
chilean's doing and actually
chalene this week is doing a uh business
school for free you can get the business
growth workshop with chalene johnson if
you go to thinkbusinessweek.com
she's sharing for five days what she
taught us over seven years ago you can
go to think businessweek.com if you want
to be a part of what she's doing there
but i think one thing that i admire so
much omar about chalene is that she's
been someone who's been able to pivot
throughout um throughout the things that
she's been doing right she's been able
to pivot and her personal brand she's
now teaching the fundamentals of how to
build that online what are some things
that you uh want people to know about
learning from chilean
yeah i think what i love about chalene
is her reputation that every time she
shows up with with tips they're usually
mind-blowing like you're like oh my gosh
i didn't even think about that like you
know like we we had her on the girl
video live show a couple days ago uh
which you can check out after this but
is her her wisdom on instagram and how
to use instagram to bring a clear
message to who you're trying to reach is
so enlightening and super helpful and
all the way down to the practicality of
like a bio makeover where she will show
you how to change
or she shows you
somebody in her community's bio which
what are you trying to do okay well if
you're trying to do that then why does
this show up in your bio did you know
that you can actually make your bio
searchable by putting you know las vegas
dentist inside of your bio so that when
people search it it shows up on
instagram but i think uh what i love
about most about her is just like she's
paying attention she's always paying
attention and a lot of these people that
we have mentioned um have 100
or what they're doing is they're
figuring it out for you and then all you
need to do is just listen and implement
obviously with the emphasis of implement
don't just listen but uh yeah she broke
down the the biggest mistakes people are
making on instagram uh on that training
so we'll link that up in the description
um and that's what i love most about her
though every time i see her show it
share a tip it's always something that
is simple yet mind-blowing but i'm
comfortable here
this is also like a stream yard
inception on inception because this was
a stream yard video and then we're on
stream yard so it's just really cool
omar that we get to create our show
inside of this but that was really uh
that was really funny to see stream yard
inside of stream yard um but yeah that
would be our uh our final one is chalene
johnson now let's just do a real quick
active review number one alex hermosie
number two gary vaynerchuk number three
vanessa lau patrick bet david sean
cannell aaron on demand and chalene
johnson now what i'm excited about is
that actually at this year's grow with
video live we have some incredible
speakers and that was just the start of
the speakers that are going to be at
grow with video live this year we also
have jasmine star we have uh anthony
o'neil omar alta corey will be on stage
uh i'll be on stage we have some amazing
speakers um that you do not want to miss
so if you've not yet registered for grow
with video live i want to encourage you
that now is the time to get your ticket
you can get an extra five percent off uh
when you go to growthvideolive.com and
use the code
gwvl show
that is how you get it omar what's the
code what's the code they need gwvlc
five percent off i'm excited and if you
can't if you can't come in person we are
we are really uh investing in a
top-notch um you know high-level online
experience where you know not not only
will there just be breakouts happening
uh in person but you're gonna have to be
able to break out and meet people on the
online uh
uh experience as well so i i think
whether you can't make it in person you
should still come to growth video live
and it's definitely gonna be uh one for
the books you know like we're sharing
these people because we don't even know
how we actually managed to get all these
people together like it's actually
insane that there's actually going to be
event an event happening this year in
2022 that these people are going to be
sharing the stage and uh i don't know
i've been to a lot of events especially
with sean when we were doing like video
influencer stuff and there there was
always a missing piece uh when i when i
would go to these different video
you know conferences or marketing
conferences and so if if you're really
looking to grow your business with
online video or build your personal
brand with online video this is the
conference to be at to learn from the
best the people who are practitioners
the people who have actually built
something and uh and i i and more than
anything i just want to meet you like if
you've been a part of the community i
think there's nothing uh more exciting
than shaking hands and saying hello
hearing your journey out face to face uh
because everything we do like i was
talking about earlier that like my life
on a weekly basis is in like a three
mile radius but then i go to a
conference and it's like everybody's
like oh my gosh i feel like i know you
i'm like
i can see why you think that but i also
uh that's weird nobody but i want to
meet you and i want to meet our
community so please come through if you
can in person but if not we'll be we'll
be uh having a great experience online
yeah it is going to be an epic
experience uh let us know in the
comments below who was a new
entrepreneur for you we'll make sure to
link up all of those entrepreneurs you
should follow as well as all of their
books because hello we are lifelong
leaders or lifelong learners so all of
their books that they have all authored
we'll make sure to link those um for you
as well if you would like to
watch another video inside of the grow
with video live show series you can do
that by clicking or tapping the screen
right now or if you want to learn more
about growth video live check out the
promo by clicking or tapping the screen
now thanks for watching we'll catch you
in the next growth video live show